في هذه الأثناء،
اجتمع وزيرا الخارجية الفلسطيني والإسرائيلي في بروكسل اليوم
لمناقشة خريطة طريق للمستقبل، فهل هناك
أي طريقة لإنهاء
إراقة الدماء بشكل دائم وكسر دائرة
العنف كما كنا نناقش للتو
بقدر ما يدعو الناس إلى قيادة جديدة
داخل إسرائيل؟  وينطبق الشيء نفسه على
الفلسطينيين حيث يقول الخبراء أن
الشعب يستحق الأفضل لقد انضممت الآن إلى
سلام فياض الذي شغل منصب رئيس وزراء
السلطة الفلسطينية وهو
ينضم إلى العرض من برينستون مرحبًا بك
مرة أخرى في البرنامج أم السيد فاد، أتساءل عما
إذا كان بإمكانك الرد  إلى Zippy Livy فيما
يتعلق بفكرة ما سيتطلبه الأمر
للحصول على
قيادة فلسطينية جديدة متمكنة وقادرة حقًا أه أو
هل تعتقد أنه يجب أن تكون هناك
قيادة جديدة أولاً وقبل
كل شيء أه شكرًا لك أه كريسان على
استضافتي في برنامجك مرة أخرى  اه اسمحوا لي
أولاً أن أقول إنني في الواقع كنت
أدعو منذ عدة سنوات إلى أن
تكون القيادة الشخصية جزءًا من
صنع مستقبل أفضل للأشخاص المتميزين أو العمل على تحقيقه،
لذلك هذا ما
يتبادر إلى ذهني على الفور عندما تقول
القيادة المستقبلية و  كل هذا
يتطلب أه الاعتراف بالحقيقة الأساسية وهي
أن الانقسام في المنزل لا يمكنه تحمله
بالتأكيد لا يمكن الاستمرار في الوقوف،
وهذا بالنسبة لي هو الأولوية الأكثر إلحاحًا التي
تواجهنا عندما يتعلق الأمر بالحديث عن
نوع مختلف من الأشخاص السلطة الفلسطينية وكل
أه التمكين  لقد
كنت أول من أقول
صراحةً إن السلطة الفلسطينية
بتشكيلها أو تشكيلها الحالي لا يمكنها حقًا
الاستمرار في الحكم، وبالتأكيد لا يمكنها
تحمل مسؤولية رعاية
احتياجات شعبنا في غزة
بالإضافة إلى الضفة الغربية.  استخدم
المصطلحات التي أعيد تشكيلها حسب ما قصدته وأنا
أكرر اليوم
التمكين السياسي وهذا يبدأ حقًا يبدأ
بمحاولة جمع السياسيين الفلسطينيين
معًا وهذا أمر لا بد منه
ثانيًا فيما يتعلق بالتعامل مع
إسرائيل بشأن الحل وكل هذا هو
الوقت المناسب  لقد حان الوقت منذ عدة
سنوات لأن المسار الذي سلكته منظمة التحرير الفلسطينية في
محاولة للوصول بنا إلى الدولة
التي أردناها على الأراضي التي
احتلتها إسرائيل في عام 1967، تبين أنه في
أفضل الأحوال ممارسة عبثية أسوأ
من  أنكم في الواقع
بعيدون جدًا عن ذلك كنتيجة مما
كنا عليه في أي وقت لأكون صادقًا معكم
الآن، إنه نوع من السخرية
بطريقة ما أنه في ذروة
الحرب المستمرة في غزة، عاد الكثير من الاهتمام
الآن إلى الظهور  في ما يسمى
بحل الدولتين، وهو أمر مثير للسخرية إلى حد ما بعد
سنوات عديدة من قول الكثير من الناس إنه
كان في أفضل الأحوال على أجهزة دعم الحياة إذا
لم يمت بالفعل بشكل جيد وجيد، فما الذي
نحن على استعداد للقيام به حيال ذلك أولاً وقبل
كل شيء لندرك في الواقع أن  إن المسار الذي
كنا نسلكه لن يأخذنا حقًا
إلى مكان أفضل، بل هو في
الواقع عملية سياسية مختلفة، عملية
تبدأ بالاعتراف
بحقوقنا الطبيعية كشعب، ومن
المهم جدًا أن تقوم قيادتنا
بصياغة رؤية فعلية بشأن ما
قد يعني هذا في الواقع في
الوقت نفسه أنه يجب عليها أيضًا أن تشغل
نفسها وتشغل نفسها بما يجب أن
يكون الأولوية الأكثر إلحاحًا على الإطلاق لإنهاء
الحرب
العدوانية المستمرة لإنهاء
الهدفين من وجهة نظري من ناحية
محاولة وضع حد لهما.  إن القدرة على
توحيدها من أجل وجود سلطة فلسطينية موحدة تحكم
من خلال
حكومة توافق عليها
السلطة الفلسطينية الموسعة لا تتعارض مع أي شيء في
الواقع في شمال شرق البلاد، ومن الضروري أن
تقدم أداة مهمة في
محاولة إنهاء الحرب.
مهم جدًا جدًا، لذلك في كل الحديث
حول ما يجب أن يحدث
للعملية السياسية وكيفية تنشيطها وكل
هذا أعتقد أنه مهم،
سيستغرق الأمر الكثير من الوقت قبل أن تتم
ترجمة كل هذا إلى خطة عمل يتم
الاتفاق عليها  وتبني
دوليا في هذه الأثناء ما
يحدث لوقف الحرب هو بالنسبة لي
الأولوية الأكثر إلحاحا مع
انشغال القيادة الفلسطينية
أولا وقبل كل شيء بهذا
الهدف وإنهاء الحرب من خلال
التأكيد والعمل على إعادة توحيد
سياستنا أعتقد ذلك بالتأكيد  من شأنه أن
يجعل نفسه ذا صلة بالمناقشة
حول المستقبل، وهذا ما
نحتاجه حقًا من أجل تنشيط
السلطة المحلية في رأيي